happy Hannukah Hannukah do you say with
a c o BB I add the CC is for
Wow okay you open yours first
no come on you open yours first no you
go no you go first
dude please open your gift first okay I
can't say no to that face okay five four
three two one
Chanukah oh my god slow cooker are you
serious this is high high quality you
like it I don't like it bench I love it
yes I'm gonna marinate meat for hours
and hours and hours and hours all the
live long day I just figured since
you've been so into bone broth dude it's
so thoughtful and adult I really
appreciate it thank you so much okay now
it's your turn
here we go you are going to love it love
it
yes yes I I do I I mean I love it I was
just like what do you get the girl who
already has everything and this just
popped into my head this did mm-hmm it
doesn't come with battery so I wrap some
in tobacco leaves for you they're also
in there there they are and there's a
sample of water based cleanser do not
wash it with soap it will deteriorate
and start to peel I wouldn't have
thought to like wash it huh
I will follow those instructions to take
good care of this oh my god dude I'm
running late I gotta go okay love you
baby love you happy Hannukah you too
thanks for my thing